you
[Music]
welcome to the final presentation of the
day I'm Amit and a mirage unfortunately
isn't able to join me on stage today but
what I'll be presenting here is a small
part of an exciting journey that we both
kind of share together in the last
couple of years as is customary how
first take a commercial break
Yelp it's all about connecting people
with great local businesses and of
commercial let's get back to the talk
all right here's the outline of the talk
so we'll be covering enough background
and context just to make sure that
you're able to get a sense of the like
understand something from the talk so
given given the the wide possible like
the spread of the audience and how much
they may or may not be aware of in terms
of spark or Kafka or Cassandra and such
we'll talk about the business
requirements that motivated and drove
this work some design iterations we went
through before coming up with the
exactly one solution and finally closed
with some remarks on ongoing work as
well so this work was actually done
within the context of local ads so
here's some background in there so we
kind of managed about a few hundred
thousand campaigns on a daily basis ad
campaigns and they ranged from
mom-and-pop stores all the way to like
national chains like say Starbucks so
what we'll be presenting today is in the
context of data processing pipelines
that receive a few thousand messages a
second and these pipelines have been in
production for more than a year I mean
the first one was yeah way more than a
year so so definitely it's been in
production for a while and there are
multiple of those all right so to get
some context and you know set up enough
background to get the business
requirements here so let's say your
business decides to advertise on Yelp
and the next one is a snapshot of a the
apps the DL per app and a user
performing a search may see like related
ads
of the the organic search results now if
the user when they view the ad or they
happen to click on an ad
maybe they call the business related to
the ad or they actually check-in in
there now all these events are logged
and you know produces a log stream
containing all these events and this log
stream then gets either processed on a
nightly basis through Hadoop jobs or is
running through around the clock day and
night Spock streaming jobs but this
processing eventually directly or
indirectly leads to reports for the
business that's advertising also they
get to see how their campaigns
performing on a business specific app
that also is a young product and then
eventually of course invoicing billing
stuff like that also happens via the
output of these jobs now what's more
relevant to this particular presentation
though is the the stream processing side
and how it powers the management of ad
campaigns so some examples here are
trends the campaign trends how they are
doing the setting of setting up of bid
prices so ads usually are kind of in an
auction system and the best ad is picked
based on the bid prices and so so the
bid price setting and also like
personalized targeting so these are some
examples of sports streaming or
screaming in general kind of enabling
the various functionalities behind the
scenes for an ad campaign so given all
these use cases we just spoke about in
the previous slide we wanted a general
solution that could aggregate events
over a day period slice these aggregates
along predefined dimensions or our keys
as you may also consider it to be and
these would be defined by the end use
case so depending on what are the uses
the dimensions could would basically be
determined by those we also want to
provide partial aggregates as the day
progresses and finally make these
aggregates as accurate as possible
because
again we are dealing with multiple use
cases they may have different
requirements so let's make this a little
more concrete with a simplified example
so let's say you want to actually count
the number of ad clicks over a day
period provide these click counts by an
ad campaign and finally like
continuously update these click numbers
as the day progresses so and the figure
at the bottom we have slap shots of the
same table over time so in the first
case at a certain time in the day let's
say we had terrified clicks reported so
far
sometimes further down in the day we may
have 42 clicks for the exact same
campaign on that same day so this is the
kind of behavior we're actually
expecting from this system so
essentially the numbers keep getting
updated and that way downstream systems
can actually act on those numbers so
what's the toolset do we have to solve
such a problem so on the Left we have
one or more data streams which could be
well at least some problem examples are
Kafka which there was a whole lot
discussed in the last talk and then
Amazon clinics Canisius is another
example there in terms of the stream
processing engines themself against Park
streaming but also flink are some
solutions there and then on the output
side we could either be emitting new
streams or we could be putting data into
a database typically a key value store
and examples there could be Cassandra or
Redis and there of course very many more
it's a much crowded space but just a few
examples that I have here and in terms
of what we use or at least in the
context of this particular talk we're
going to kind of stay focused on Kafka's
box streaming and Cassandra on the
output end alrighty so one more thing
before we kind of actually talk about a
solution is the windowed operations the
idea of minor operations in in stream
processing so at the top you see a
tumbling window which is kind of where
data is so I should maybe mention first
that
yeah in general stream processing you
have like events coming in and there are
definitely a lot of use cases where
you're just processing one event at a
time in a stateless fashion but the more
interesting use cases are typically
where you are actually doing operations
over a window of events and so a
tumbling window would be where you have
non-overlapping of windows of time like
the example we're talking about I've
been aggregating over a day window for
example where each of these could be a
day boundary and then we're trying to do
some kind of aggregation or whatever
operation within that context there's
also other kinds of windows sliding
windows another example where they're
actually overlapping windows of time
there is also like session windows which
are accession based for example user
sessions so so there's definitely
multiple kinds of ways you can window
things but for the purposes of what are
we going to talk today
tumbling windows what we care about all
right so back to our original problem we
wanted to account clicks over the period
of a day so why don't we just do this
why don't we just kind of take this
stream in we just talked about tumbling
windows so we just kind of bucket it
over day window and then have this
processing pipeline just produce this
final sum on the other end the number of
clicks so why not just go with this well
basically two things one of course is
the the fact that tumbling windows don't
produce anything until the end of the
window is read so it's it's kind of a
stateful system it's kind of internally
aggregating your data and then finally
when the windows done is when you have
the final number so that's when it emits
the output so clearly the requirement we
had was oh we need to kind of see
partial aggregates as the day proceeds
which means in this case that's not
going to work if you're actually going
to be waiting till the end of the day
before we get a number we might as well
have just gone with batch processing at
that point
all right so how about we don't depend
on that but instead kind of just taking
a
bunch of events do just aggregation
within the scope of those events a lot
less I mean so we're not talking about
day window anymore let's say a few
minutes or maybe even seconds whatever
aggregate just whatever we just got in
and then kind of let the database take
care of the deltas so essentially we
send an increment and then on the
database side we just basically have it
to the the work of aggregating and
keeping a the final state in there and
that kind of was something we looked
into which kind of looked promising
because Cassandra does have a data type
called counter where H is an integer
type we can do increments and decrements
and so it seemed like okay maybe this
could work but doing a little more into
it we found out that it's actually not
meant to be idempotent so it's great for
approximate metrics like likes follows
stuff like that but not so much for when
you want to have higher levels of
accuracy I mean so we did talk to data
stacks the company behind Cassandra in
many ways and they actually reported as
much as 5% discrepancy in terms of just
what they've heard from the industry at
large and a lot of the this also is case
driven I mean the discrepancies come are
a result of the distributed nature of
Cassandra and how things propagate
across the cluster and also the the 5%
or up to 5% is really a result of how
you use it as well so it's not really a
single defined way or single defined
bound on what you what discrepancies you
might get and finally they also
mentioned that they have no plans or
roadmap at all in terms of making it an
important down in the down the road as
well so it was not something we could
kind of wait for and then kind of
improve our accuracy on all righty so
this is what we came back to so okay so
it doesn't look like we can use tumbling
windows it's not like we can use
Cassandra and leverage any kind of
increment like operation on that that
side so what we could potentially do is
kind
take care of the incrementing within the
processing pipeline and then publish
back the final result so essentially
read in the current values Cassandra as
the current as a state for keeping the
current counts and then do the
increments for the new data that comes
in and then publish it back to Cassandra
so that way
you're kind of doing the work in the
processing pipeline but you're keeping
Cassandra as a way to kind of keep that
state track the state so what does that
look like in terms of actually doing a
pipeline so for that let's just quickly
go over a few one-on-ones and then we'll
jump into okay what would it look like
from a pipeline perspective so you've
heard a lot about Kafka in the last talk
but that was more on the architecture or
more on the operational and
infrastructural side of things this is
more on the application layer so this is
just a one single slide quick review of
Kafka and this is all we really need for
the purposes of this presentation so
Kafka the data is organized our
perdition
into partitions and each partition has a
notion of an offset so data in in the
botton is order and they have a
well-defined
offset kind of an index into that
particular data block and the consumers
who consume this data have to kind of
keep track there of their own progress
meaning if a consumer is consuming from
say the first partition if they're read
as far as offset for and the next they
want to read offset five in the the
information about how far they've
progressed on that particular partition
is something the it's the consumers
responsibility but Kafka does provide
ways to actually persist that
information so the consumer can actually
send that or commit that offset to Kafka
and Kafka will hold it for you but it's
still your responsibility do that work
alrighty so that was Kafka and then the
other piece we wanted is spot streaming
here again single slide just the basics
that we need for this
click on talk there's of course a lot
more to all these systems so let's say
we have these streams coming in this
processing going on the way it works is
traditional spock streaming you do micro
batching meaning something like you tear
out a stream a few records from the
front of the stream you process that and
then once you're done with that then you
can again tear out the next batch and
then process that again so there's no
pipelining meaning that you completely
process the current micro batch before
you start processing the next by crach
and even within the pipeline if you had
multiple stages again there's no
pipelining meaning stage one will
completely finish processing and then
stage two will completely finish
processing and then stage two will start
and finish processing so there's no
parallel execution of multiple stages
going on internally and finally the app
basically has to manage the offset
commits so so back and on the previous
slide we were talking about how the
consumer has to take care of the
committing of offsets so it's the same
deal here it's just that the spark
streaming layer doesn't take care of it
or at least in this context the best
guarantees are provided if the app
basically manages the the commits so the
app has to keep track of how far it's
progressed and then essentially go back
and commit that information wherever to
either to Kafka or whatever they stored
it wants to use so all right so we have
the tools so let's kind of put these two
two two together and see what it looks
like what a system might look like based
on the idea we came up with before so on
the left you have the the data stream
kind of coming in we kind of tear off a
micro batch and then stage one
essentially what we could do is
aggregate just the information in this
case clicks we just kind of add up all
the clicks for a campaign as part of the
first stage and then stage two is going
to receive the the dimensions or the
keys like in this particular case it
would be the the campaign ID and then
the the day
as inputs from stage 1 so that stage 2
can actually get that information for
the current count from the database from
Cassandra and then finally in stage 3 we
would have the current state we will
also have the increment that we wanted
and then we combined them and then that
way we can publish it back to the
datastore we would have the new value
and then at the last like once these
three stages have succeeded finally what
we could do is kind of commit the offset
based on how far we've made progress so
this particular micro batch let's say it
took first four records out of the
stream so we have successfully processed
that we have the updates in Cassandra so
we can basically do that commit so then
the next time we read and basically
going to start from opposite five so
looks good so far are there any problems
well like to kind of coat cannon all
here of course it's a very dense slide
but just the the highlighted regions is
basically the point here that's that
distributed systems it's all about
failures so that's what you design for
and that's kind of your primary concern
so and it's a distinguishing factor
between local programming versus
distributed programming so so you're
always kind of looking for the failures
when you're kind of developing for the
distributed world all right so let's see
what it means in terms of failure modes
all right so what happens if stage one
fails for a reason so so let's say we
kind of either throw an exception and
then we fail stage one boxing spark
basically has this retry on stages and
so you can basically configure that
so it'll retry that particular stage but
in any case I mean stage one is really
doing reads there's no side effect
there's no real writing going on so it's
essentially safe so stage one if it kind
of fails retries retries horribly and
then the whole application restarts no
problems at all
stage one is good all right what about
stage to stage two does read from the
database but again there are
side effects nothing at all and then
there's no pipelining so unless stage 3
unless stage to succeed stage 3 it's not
even going to start so there's no side
effect again no problems stage 2 is good
alright so stage 3 things get a little
interesting
so now stage 3 let's say starts writing
to the datastore and then fails
somewhere in between and so some of the
records in the database have been
updated so some of the campaigns have
updated clicks while let's say the rest
of them don't and then let's say the
whole application crashes at that point
now when the application restarts we did
not do any commits for the ones that
were successful and so we're just back
to wherever the offsets were in the
previous micro batch so we're going to
readjust exactly the same data or at
least all of the data from the previous
micro batch and then go through these
processing stages except the problem now
is that the records that were updated
now stage 2 is going to get those
updated values and then the the same
data is going to come in and there's
nothing to distinguish between the two
and so it's going to actually increment
it again so we go to basically increment
those values twice before committing
back to stage 3 so essentially we have
over counting at this point and also the
feeling more on the on the last one
where we do commit is again the same in
the sense that if we didn't commit and
the application fails at that point we
are going again going to readjust data
from the previous micro batch and in
this case we did not we're going to
double count everything because we
essentially committed everything in the
previous micro batch so what it comes
down to is essentially we have failure
modes where we going to over count and
not really get the right counts so one
aspect is that we saw that there were
only like failure modes where we were
over counting like we're never under
counting so that's kind of a good thing
I mean essentially we're always kind of
erring on the side of ingesting data
that we've already either processor or
not processed and hence we're always
going to get the data and never miss
data but on the other hand like we are
going to be able we are gonna be over
counting in some cases some failure
modes so how do we go from that to
achieving exactly once so here's kind of
the the basic observations in terms of
coming up with that solution so one
thing is we are clearly not able to
distinguish between processed versus
unprocessed data and that's basically
where the over-counting is coming from
one way to look at it is like okay if
there is a way to kind of version our
aggregates or our the some data then we
don't have you could figure out a way
where the same data comes back in we're
like oh this still belongs to the old
version we don't have to count this so
we're doing kind of is a way or at least
we could come up with a strategy which
kind of looks like versioning to achieve
this and of course one thing with
versioning is that oh they're always
more automatically increasing aversions
always go up by the same time the nice
thing is that Kafka partitions data is
already ordered they have a notion of
offset and they are also incrementing
all the time so if you can combine these
two aspects we can come up with a
solution and in fact that's what we did
all right so let's see what that looks
like so here's an example we're just
going to take let's say one particular
ad campaign ID five and we're going to
take click data so if there's a CLK in a
particular event which means that we did
get a click if there is nothing that
means we didn't get a click on that
particular event and the table of course
looks like before except for the extra
column now so we have a column called
version and let's see what we do here so
we take the data we process it and then
once we are done with processing we take
the highest offset corresponding to the
data that we've already processed and
that's what becomes the version so in
this particular case campaign is five ID
five and then we have three clicks at
the time where we are offset two so the
number of clicks is three and then by
then we basically are saying that okay
version is two because we have processed
as far as opposite to now for whatever
reason if your uh name
to commit this so we process till
officer two we're unable to commit the
application crashes comes back up we
ingest the same data you're going to
have offset zero one and two but when
you read the current state from
Cassandra you're going to have version
two coming along with it which means
that we can now kind of discard the data
zero through two because the version is
two and we already process till two so
we only process data that's higher than
the version like the offsets higher than
the version that we've already processed
so of course we may have more than one
row or campaign ID so we have to
maintain this version on a per dimension
economy or primarykey basis so in this
particular case we're again process
still opposite to but as far as the ID
nine is concerned one is the highest
offset that we have process so far for
that particular campaign and then for ID
five yeah we've gone basically to offset
two and so the version is based on the
highest offset that we a process for a
particular key or a particular primary
key combination so that's the basic idea
of course the other thing is that yeah
there might be more than one petition so
it's not just a matter of one number as
far as the version is concerned so on a
per primary key basis we also want to
kind of track which partition and what
the offset is so so essentially that's
the idea as to how we keep track of
versions and how we can kind of avoid
over counting so what does it look like
as far as the pipeline is concerned with
this modification well things have moved
around a little bit so now stage one is
actually doing the read from the
database so it's not only getting the
the current state but it's also getting
the version corresponding to that
particular set of keys and then this is
then fed into stage 2 so stage 2 is
getting two pieces of data one is the
diversions corresponding to the keys
from stage one and then it's also
getting the actual events
from the micro batch and then that's
doing the work of discarding away things
that are not that's a there are equal to
a below the version and then only doing
the aggregation on the remaining and
then that's the Delta that we feed into
stage three and then stage three is also
getting the current state from Cassandra
from stage one and so combined together
stage he can now reliably count them
both together aggregate them both
together and then write it back to the
database and then finally the the commit
can do what it was doing before so in
this modified version now have we solved
the overcrowding problem well let's talk
about stage one again stage one is done
doing reads no side effects nothing at
all not a whole lot different from the
previous version we had so safe again
stage two no big deal
no reads no side effects perfectly safe
Stage three so back to how we were doing
it before so we could do kind of partial
writes and then fail on it but now when
we do that the ones that have not been
updated the versions are also not being
updated for those particular rows and so
if the application crashes comes back
and then the data gets fed in back again
the version numbers for those which have
not been updated yet will be the the
previous version number where we have
but for the ones that have been
successfully updated in stage three
we're actually going to get the updated
version numbers which means stage two is
now going to discard the versions
corresponding I mean the data
corresponding to those and so we are not
going anymore over count in stage three
so stage three is now kind of or the
pipeline as a whole is not going to kind
of over count under this failure mode
and likewise with the final like commit
failing same idea only difference is
that yeah will basically be discarding
all the data from the previous micro
batch in this particular case so if
that's all the data that comes in again
then we are basically going to go do
zero updates to the database at that
point
all right so so far I mean well we've
been talking about like addition like
adding the number of clicks stuff for
that but the real thing is that this
doesn't have to be limited to just
additions or even simple mathematical
operations aggregation logic in general
is actually now residing in the pipeline
so all these deltas are being computed
in the pipeline which means you have
complete control over what that logic is
so it can be arbitrary complex it can be
you know like richer data set like the
data structures it could be orbital
anything that you want to compute as
long as you have a well-defined
aggregation function you could basically
carry out any kind of operation here so
that kind of generalizes the idea and
you know lets it apply to a lot more use
cases and in terms of what's next to
some some ongoing work I mean given the
the generalization aspect of it like one
of the things that we are kind of
working on or at least implementing at
this point our window joins so again
joins could actually be treated as a
specialization of aggregation
just because joins are nothing more than
kind of merging together a few different
kinds of or pieces of data together and
the advantage we would have as opposed
to using the traditional join mechanisms
or whatever is already provided by the
processing engine is that now you can
have arbitrary business rules as far as
the joints are concerned so essentially
things like if you had like let's say
three different streams are coming in
and you're trying to join events across
those based on app key it's possible
that maybe two of them have and have the
key while the third one doesn't and your
business logic may require maybe that oh
I want all three of them to actually
have a key for me to a successful em in
something but there might be other
scenarios where it's like oh I
okay with you know these two streams
having data even if the third doesn't
have it I'm perfectly fine with still
emitting an output so things like that
actually now can be performed because
now we have arbitrary control over what
the aggregation process
and another aspect they were also kind
of working on is due duplication as part
of the aggregation framework more so
because typically when you have data
being published to Kafka or in general
like any kind of publisher set of story
the these publishers are not typically
idempotent and so the input streams
could end up having duplicates from the
previous processing pipeline and which
actually will be impacting the the
current pipeline because the aggregation
is now getting the same data more than
once but we are not going to kind of
dedupe that out by default because we
are not looking at the the keys that
make them duplicates we're actually
looking at the the primary keys and the
primary keys wise we have already saw
this problem but due to application is
still needed for the input data itself
so that's another thing we're kind of
looking into in terms of already
implementing in terms of having that as
part of the aggregation step because
that's where it actually has an impact
so that just some closing remarks I mean
you know I just wanted to throw out
there we are hiring across a wide set of
skill sets and so please to check out
the the career pages careers page if
you're interested in learning out about
that more
and also there's like a whole bunch of
places you can look in terms of in terms
of looking at our culture or just what
we've been doing lately stuff like that
so you could yeah visit any of these and
get some more information there as well
and thanks for listening thank you
maybe I missed this but how do you deal
with out of order data sure yeah the
question is how do you deal with out of
order data so just just the way it's
typically the case I mean essentially
you kind of you could define a window
and then just throw things out beyond a
certain point I mean for example we are
kind of collecting for the most part
like the aggregates over the yesterday
progresses and so yeah we don't
the next day you probably don't care
about the previous day and that's could
be a kind of a reasonable old boundary
at which you say okay any new data
coming in after this point we don't
anymore bucket into the old day we just
kind of discarded we filtered so see
that's kind of yeah that's something
that how that happens on an earlier
stage I mean it's of aggregation isn't
really going it's going to kind of
aggregate everything that comes to it
but then the initial ingestion stages
basically would be the place where these
calf folders will be applied where yeah
they were discounted I know you talked
to the beginning having flink or just
spark streaming how's your experience
with using one or the other and whereas
it helped you or hurt you can you repeat
that that's part I'm saying at the
beginning you said use spark streaming
and flink or you you mentioned both of
them have you worked with trade-off
search in there for yourself sure Thanks
so so we started using Spock streaming
like quite a few years ago and flink was
in kind of at a point where it's it was
mature enough and so yeah back then link
was not even a candidate among the ones
considered so a lot of the work that's
been happening has been in Spock
swimming for that matter I mean I've
kind of been kind of expanding on that
in terms of link I mean like the team I
belong to or at least I belong to and to
recently like yeah we were completing
the Spock swimming wall weather other
parts of the organization that's kind of
investing in flying and they're kind of
working it out but I guess the one
aspect to it I could say is that in
either case I mean like the biggest
problems or the biggest things I've had
to build on were more around state
management and the the lifecycle of
state management so that's
basically where the a lot of the things
had to people kind of outside of or like
kind of had to be strapped on on top of
these frameworks to kind of make sure
that in a production use case we kind of
continue to kind of work over a longer
period of time so I think in that regard
they kind of have maybe not the same set
of problems but still estate management
is an issue and I guess both are making
improvements and hopefully we will see
yeah its proximate is next week and that
clean forward had yeah a few
announcements from before so so yeah
hopefully we're hoping to see some more
progress there but otherwise until then
we kind of canoeing doing it ourselves
outside of the frameworks
[Music]